comme une partie du corps valérie benaïm
même une partie du corps que tu voudrais
bien chacun des joueurs assis autour de
la table alors bien sûr crystal display
tradewest la poitrine de benjamin bravo
je prendrai le port de tête de géraldine
et je prendrai le sourire de kelly est
assez bon ça suffit déjà était déjà très
élevée n'avait pas besoin de ça juste la
poitrine je suis pas sûr que tu es pris
les rênes de trop mais surtout en
plastique comme ça d' équité chose à
attendre au super days donnent trois
moments d'apt n'a pas envie d'embrasser
fatou
le matin au petit déjeuner quand à la
patrie son café quand elle sort des
toilettes et je la regarde et
on
voit tout est tranquillement en train
des moules et inquiète l'occident
mais
[Musique]
non tu attends pas tout mafate ou
qu'est-ce qu'une frère
[Musique]
non mais c'est quand même extraordinaire
que vous attendez pas tous derrière la
porte des toilettes et dans 5 minutes
à tout a fini
derrière la porte la porte est ouverte
ces journées portes ouvertes
intimité dans l'intimité de quoi qu'on
attendait à l'époque on nous dira que
pas tout fait caca la porte ouverte si
je suis là oui
mais sans déconner quoi face aux médias
c'est pas disgracieux on peut on peut
parler mais vous recevez des amis quand
même
dans les toilettes au milieu du salon
c'est l'amour en tout cas mes invités
jamais chef pâtissière va vous invitez
on a trouvé une date à vous proposer ah
bah vous en perdez pas
c'était quand la date début janvier au
beau frère qui
s'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors assis dit que c'est vrai et c'est
faux en tout cas c'est une belle info
géraldine maillet 6 3 trucs que tu
pourrais faire tous les jours jusqu'à la
fin de ta vu faire l'amour manger du
panier tonnes et aller jouer au tennis
et pas laisser passer ça rien dit quoi
vous ben moi j'aurais dit vouloir
castaldi doit
déjà ça non mais c'est vrai parce que je
sais que je ne peux pas me voir et
énormément de fans
tori a dit quoi bon remariée non mariés
non j'aurais dit quoi on va encore votre
laissez tomber vous demandez à
quoi je n'en ai pas c'est une ces deux
questions subsidiaires je suis content
mairie attention donc si trois façons de
tester l'amitié de ton pote jean michel
meyer lui laissais ma meuf une nuit
minutes peuvent s'amuser minutes et dans
votre loge
à port sainte marie dans l'aisne vous à
mon avis oui faisait juste à vannes on
n'est plus mon ami puis 50 mais où les
tiers
ça revient il faut qu'il prenne qui
pourront
m'aider non michel meyer fait gaffe tu
peux aller vous chercher en thaïlande
c'est oublier tes oublier ces oubliés
eux c'est dégueulasse guillaume genton
trouve trois choses pour fuir pour faire
faire un coup d'un soir
péter
dire que je peux te dire que je t'ai pas
l'addition et
dire que je suis une femme
enseigne a que vous qui avez aimé t il
est très sympa mais il est patent
attention question nomme trois choses
que tu peux faire en moins de trois
minutes castaldi kaka
l'amour
est toujours autant de répartir l'effort
c'est de l'argent
dépensé de l'argent ici nulle en moins
de trois minutes au
fait un effort non mais
il imagine 3 façon de dissimuler le truc
groupe horrible que tu as répondu aux
chiottes
alors je mets beaucoup de papiers je
tiens la chasse plusieurs fois et je
lassitude et jeu
- bonduelle moi moi moi m'en tienne moi
mon chéri
[Rires]
chéri ben haim 6-3 maison de continuer
d'espérer alors que target messi jouera
que répondre parce que je suis optimiste
parce que je pense que
les
attentions même question pour isabelle
morini bosc a même pas compris la
question
[Applaudissements]
on a fait pas remarquer si vous voulez
mettre que les gongs on va le faire
vous gong et la gueule
trois raisons de continuer d'espérer
alors que target messi jouera tu
répondre évidemment je m'en fous non non
je reste optimiste et ensuite je
patiente le futur voyageur est arrivé
bwa bwa bwa bwa bwa bwa bwa bwa bwa
truc c'est rien ça renforce le dentier
et partout 6/3 moment où il faut mettre
des gants jean michel maire quand je me
lave maintenant je vais aux toilettes
et quand je serre la main quand je
j'embrasse dirigeante on sait
aujourd'hui que
non à des gosses qui est ce qu il a dit
vous caressez guillaume genton non pas
si on a un passif tous les deux c'est
quoi le passif non match j'ai pris parce
que actif
on arrête tout à 19 heures quand j'aurai
tout cela donne à dia fin sylvie vartan
nous regardent avec attention dit alors
vas-y non parce que vous savez jouer a
raconté que je vous avais présenté une
fille qui sont en contact avant lui
avons mis à son compte à qui il l'a pas
empêché de l'embrasser genre après oui
et il se trouve que cet instrument que
cette copine on lui a donné une deuxième
chance elle a rencontré il ya toujours 2
2 et voilà mais là le
chien se feront
elles me voient le vomi dans trois réac
restantes annexe parce qu'elle était
contente non mais sans rémunérer six
mois auquel vous voilez beau mais je les
recroiser comme ça par hasard par hasard
la baignoire
il a croisé par hasard c'est vous alors
ouais elle a vomi immédiatement non
c'est un eric jourde et de quitter
l'aventuré c'est là
qu'après la résurrection chiffré à 6
elle a vomi directe au mondial est venu
c'est que tu me plais en revanche fait
quatre miss peut-être parce qu'elle est
trop mais mis en
place était de l'acteur la société de la
peur quand elle est contente elle vomit
fouet par la c
est à dire merci kelly en tout cas de
relever les
défis nés malformés chez le maire d
attention qualité dominici trois choses
que les mecs désire plus que tout un
buffet arriver les faits c'est
bon à bois bois bwa bwa bwa bwa bwa
attention géraldine maillet 6-3 chose
que les mecs désire plus que tout mes
fesses les sans noms mais l'argent de la
carrière mais non mais non non non non
et s'ils avaient su de ouais c'est pas
mais naïm une meuf une voiture et
un super super appart d'accord moi je
pense à guillaume genton non mais c'est
vrai que c'est ce que vous consommez
trois passions c'est vrai c'est quoi
votre passion première pécho par l'amour
et ken
monomaniaque
mais le produit oui non et el kharroubi
[Applaudissements]
grâce à cette vanne vous aurez le droit
de défendre françois hollande sur une
phrase a
dit hier que tu es excusez moi
vous n'êtes vous êtes qui ça va non mais
c'est comme moi j'écoute qu'à tampa même
temps de passer concrètement il est
dangereux de la ville indique ta vie tu
as une d'hier thaïlande week-end très
compliqué oui bon c'est quoi le pont
alors à la raison
vous êtes là pour écouter on n'entendait
pas mais vous écouter non mais c'est
vrai oui alors j'étais en séminaire de
travail à genève je n'étais pas là bas
je vous ai appelé vous étiez sur
messagerie oui et j'ai re voilà un gros
séminaire de travail à genève allait
dépêcher
j'étais en tournage voilà j'étais en
tournage à genève commence à se jeter au
qu'on allait dépêcher des copies des
mails vous n'avez pas lu les noms mais
voilà j'ai vu une amie à genève qui
serait leonidas exactement ces pages il
voyage mais
c'est vrai qu'ils voyagent beaucoup mais
beaucoup de séminaires aussi donc et qui
s'est passé mais on a visité les musées
en six mois terminées mesure vos
maltings connaît
la suite nuptiale de l'hôtel beau rivage
quoi c'est vrai a bien sûr quoi gilles
vous avez des infos c'était la poule 1
jeudi 1 à waimes je n'écoute pas trop
tôt aux mille euros la nuit non ah ouais
j'ai tracé commun une heure trois nuls
quoi c'est pas vrai ben hassine 3/2 dès
samedi bonjean fille différente
non pas du tout hi hi hi lo quoi bon
savoir que je joue sans chaleur mais ça
va alors j'aimerais vous êtes dans un
jacuzzi
il a alors que je balance tout peut
alors aller balancer aux knicks maurice
dessens mes deux filles différentes
une suissesse et une venue de l'autre
côté de la frontière
est d'accord d'habitude il leur promet
monts et merveilles
s'il vous plaît ça mais dans leur
quartier
calmez-vous si au pl le procureur je
retire voilà mais en fait j'étais sous
le choc du vomi no fake je m'aère
l'esprit bateau je suis parti voilà la
voûte plantaire parenté entre damon
d'accord
certes votre barre ovomaltine
la dynamite
c'est ma vie puis une fois merci gilles
d'autres infos sur ce qu'on avait dit me
calmer sur quelqu'un d'autre et si vous
n'êtes pas une petite info comme ça la
volée non ça va ça va
les oreilles il commence à terroriser
tout le monde en loge où il arrive
maintenant quelqu'un et à sion en loge
une styliste en l'occurrence et il dit
c'est montiel c'est ma place dégagé et
il dit benjamin était là donc il peut
démarrer et il dit à l'autre et vamouty
le maire l'a montré il dit à l'autre et
20 hommes et va me prendre comme
d'habitude mais deux bouteilles d'eau
dans le frigo et ramène tous les soirs
chez lui deux bouteilles d'eau en disant
c'est pas vraiment au moins j'ai pas ça
a payé ses scieries qui paye
ai je pour moi je crois gilles verdez à
ce que j'en sais pas je suis témoin
c'est vrai c'est vrai je suis allé à
mallarmé c'est vrai